are you your body
well kind of right but is there a line
where this stops being true
how much of yourself can you remove
before you stop
being new and does the question even
makes sense
your physical existence is cells
trillions of them
at least 10 times more than there are
stars in the milky way
a cell is a living being a machine made
of up to 50
000 different proteins it has no
consciousness
no will no purpose it just is
but it is still an individual together
your cells form huge structures for jobs
like preparing food
gathering resources transporting stuff
around
scanning the environment and so on
if you extract cells from your body and
put them in the right environment
they will continue to stay alive for a
while so
your cells can exist without you but you
can't exist without them if we take all
the cells away
there is no you anymore is there a line
where a pile of your cells
stops being new for example if you
donate an organ
billions of your cells will continue to
live on inside someone else
does this mean that a part of you became
a part of another person
or is this other body keeping a part of
you
alive or let us imagine an experiment
you and a random person from the street
exchange cells
one at a time your body gets one of
their cells
their body gets one of your cells at
which point would they become
you would they ever or is this just a
very slow and
gross way to teleport you let's make
this more complicated
the image of ourselves as a static thing
is untenable
almost all of your cells have to die
during your lifetime
250 million have died since the
beginning of this video alone
between one and three million per second
in a seven year period most of your
cells are replaced at least once
every time your cell set up changes you
are slightly different than before
so a part of you is dying constantly
if you are lucky enough to become old
you would have cycled through roughly a
million
billion cells so what you consider
yourself
is really just a snapshot but sometimes
cells are broken and don't want to die
questioning the very nature of the unity
of our bodies
we call them cancer they cancel the
biological social contract
and become basically immortal cancer is
not an
outside invader it's a part of you that
puts its own survival over yours
but you could also argue that a cancer
cell becomes another entity inside us
another being that just wants to thrive
and survive
can we blame it for that a chilling cell
story
is that of henrietta lacks a young
cancer patient who died in 1951
usually cells only survived for a few
days in the lab
making research very hard henrietta's
cancer cells were
immortal over the decades they were
multiplied over and over again
and used for countless research projects
saving countless lives
henrietta's cells are still alive and
overall have been grown to at least
20 tons of biomass so there are living
parts around the world
from someone who has been considered
dead for decades
how much of henrietta is in these cells
what makes one of your cells you anyway
maybe the information contained in it
your dna until recently it was believed
that all the cells in your body had
basically the same genetic code
but it turns out this is wrong your
genome is mobile
changing over time through mutations and
environmental influences
this is especially the case in your
brain according to recent discoveries
a single neuron in an adult brain has
more than one thousand mutations in its
genetic code
that are not present in the cells
surrounding it but how much
you is your dna really about eight
percent of the human genome is made up
of viruses that once infected our
ancestors and merged with us
mitochondria power plants of the cell
once were bacteria that merged with the
ancestors of your cells
they still have their own dna an average
cell has
hundreds of them hundreds of little
things that are not really human but
they still kind of
are it is confusing
let's backtrack a bit we know that
you're made up of trillions of little
things
made from more little things that are
constantly changing
together all those little things are not
static but dynamic
their composition and condition is
changing constantly
so we might just be a self-sustaining
pattern
without clear borders that gained
self-awareness at some point
and now has the ability to think about
itself through time and space
but ready only exists in this exact very
moment
where did this pattern start with your
conception
when the first human arose when life
first began conquering our small planet
or when the elements that make up your
body were forged in a star
our human brains evolved to deal with
absolutes
the fuzzy borders that make up reality
are hard to grasp
maybe ideas like beginning and end life
and death
you and me are really not absolutes
but ideas belonging to a fluent pattern
a pattern that is lost
in this strange and beautiful universe
the problem of who we are isn't just a
question of ourselves
but it's also a question of our minds
just as our cells can be divided and
separated from us
so can our very brains be divided and
while still in the skull click here to
go to my channel
and watch the next part okay so now go
watch cgp grey's video
if you're not yet subscribed to his
channel you should really change that
now